the doctor said it was the weirdest rash she's ever seen
just like a map of
just checking in do you need anything else
oh I love another iced tea
and then I finally told them I have a third nipple
is everything tasting all right
yeah yeah
it's right so my neighbor trained their pet parrot to steal my mail
and they're asking anything else to drink
oh I'll
another iced tea yeah
so I went on a blind date
and it turns out the guy is a mime
everything else with your mains?
oh yeah
some cheese this is right
this is perfect yeah yeah
we'll we'll take some Parmesan
and I found out that she's been raising an army of squirrels
anyone plan for something sweet
oh uh
I think we're okay do you want dessert